this video is kindly sponsored by keeps
find out more later in the video hey 42
here
in the southeast of england on the banks
of the river way
sits a quaint leafy town known as
waybridge
it's prim streets are lined with artisan
coffee shops and bohemian boutiques
and aside from once hosting the marriage
of henry viii to catherine howard
it's enjoyed a fairly uneventful past
but earlier this year the town's
residents were scandalized
by a mystery tree fella who
under cover of darkness took a chainsaw
to nearly 50 trees
instead of taking the wood home with him
this
timber tyrant left his woody corpses
strewn across the town's paths
roads and river leaving the locals with
an unsightly mess and a number of
unsettling questions
why if the culprit didn't need the wood
did he embark on such a destructive
spree
how did he manage to cut down so many
trees without making a sound
and if a tree falls but nobody is there
to hear it
does it still make a sound
whilst you're sitting there pondering
philosophical questions such as this
you could also be saving your hair using
keeps
i've had people close to me start to
lose their hair as early as their
twenties
and it's always an upsetting experience
if you're in the same boat then you're
not alone did you know
two out of three guys will experience
some form of male pattern baldness
by the time they're 35 but the best
thing you can do to prevent hair loss is
take the initiative right now and do
something about it
whilst you've still got hair left you
used to have to go to the doctor's
office for a hair loss prescription
but now thanks to keeps you can visit an
online doctor and get the medication you
need
delivered directly to your door i like
keeps because it makes treatment super
easy by delivering your hair loss
medication
every three months so you can say
goodbye to awkward doctor visits
and waiting in pharmacy checkout lines
there's a reason that keeps has more
five-star reviews than any of its
competitors
and hundreds of thousands of men trust
them
for their hair loss prevention
medication if
you're like me you're probably not ready
to lose your hair
just yet but prevention is key
the faster you act the faster you'll see
results and the sooner you start using
keeps the more hair you'll save so
if you're noticing that you're losing
your hair do something about it
for a limited time go to keeps.com
forward slash 42
or click the link in the description
below to receive 50
off your first order don't miss out
perhaps that last question didn't
unsettle the residence as much as the
first two
but once upon a time it did preoccupy
the mind of an inquisitive irish bishop
george barkley who although it's debated
may have been the first person to ask
that very question
barkley was an 18th century philosopher
who spent a lot of time
pondering the nature of well nature
philosophers are known for questioning
things that others generally take for
granted
like free will for example or whether
there's a china teapot orbiting the sun
of course there is but in 1710
berkeley decided to out philosophize
everyone
by claiming that the entire physical
world
just plainly doesn't exist
you see berkeley was an idealist
not in the way that word is often thrown
around today
to mean someone who's a little bit naive
like your grandma who just doesn't
understand why that mr putin man on the
news
can't just make friends with everyone no
barkley subscribed to a philosophical
doctrine called
idealism idealists believe that the
essential nature of reality doesn't lie
in the material world around us but in
things like
consciousness ideas and reason
it's a tricky concept to get your head
around and you wouldn't be alone in
raising an eyebrow or two
when the writer samuel johnson
discovered barclay's view
he was so outraged that he kicked a
large stone
and declared i refute it thus
and that's because many of us subscribe
to the pretty intuitive belief
that there is a physical world one that
exists completely independently
from us we know this because our senses
feed us information about it every
second
and because well if we don't exist in a
physical world
where the hell are we but
barkley believed that the things our
senses tell us about reality
and reality itself are actually
the same thing
take a familiar object like a strawberry
it has
knowable properties it's red small
a little bumpy and sweet but now
try to imagine that strawberry without
the redness
and without its shape or its texture or
its taste
it's pretty much impossible because what
is a strawberry
without its properties so if objects are
inseparable from their properties
and those properties can only be
perceived as sensory experiences
in our minds then there can't be a
physical world that exists separately to
us right this was barclays doctrine
essa est passippi or to be
is to be perceived if we aren't there to
perceive an object
it simply doesn't exist
now briefly returning to johnson's foot
kicking
the stone barkley would have expected
him to feel
pain but he would also have argued that
the stone
didn't exist outside of the sensory
experiences it created
i.e pain and so if a tree falls in a
forest
but nobody is there to hear it then
according to barclay no it doesn't make
a sound
because there is no tree
that all sounds completely mental i know
but berkeley wasn't the first
philosopher to question
our relationship with reality around 70
years earlier
rene descartes released his magnum opus
mediations on first philosophy
in the second mediation he considers how
everything he knows about a piece of wax
its smell colour and texture
changes once the fire melts it
the wax itself remains but the sensory
experiences
don't then he rambles on about
wax and his limbs for another five pages
before eventually reasserting a famous
maxim he'd originally penned four years
earlier
i think therefore i am
around this time science was having a
lot of fun overturning
most of what we knew about the world in
the 1660s robert hook discovered the
cell
showing that all living organisms are
composed of
tiny structural units that are
imperceptible to the human eye
meanwhile isaac newton took an interest
in colours
[Music]
which in hindsight wasn't his smartest
move
because in a dramatic demonstration of
dedication to knowledge
he prodded the underneath of his eyeball
by shoving a blunt
sewing needle called a bodkin inside his
eye socket
just to see what would happen but every
masochistic act has a silver lining
because in doing so he proved that white
light
is composed of a spectrum of seven
visible colors
and if light itself is the source
of color then it couldn't be a property
that
belonged to external objects objects
have no colour instead
they reflect light which our brains then
interpret as colour
so with scientists everywhere suddenly
bulldozing
every long-established axiom it's hardly
surprising that philosophers began to
question
the reality of the world if an
experience as fundamental
as color is purely a manifestation
originating
within our minds how much influence do
we actually have
on reality of course this kind of
skepticism wouldn't be very useful in
everyday life
imagine for example explaining to your
neighbor that you didn't feed her cat
because there is no cat so
let's just presume for the time being
that i really exist
you really exist and there are
definitely things out there called trees
that exist independently of us
if one of them fell but you or i
weren't there to hear it would it make a
sound
well put simply the answer is
it depends how you define sound
according to psychoacoustics the study
of how
humans perceive sound when a tree falls
it compresses the air particles around
it causing them to vibrate
the faster it falls the more they
vibrate
those air particles then vibrate the
particles around
them creating air waves these waves
travel through the air at 343 meters per
second
transferring energy to surrounding
objects
if your ear was one of those objects
a spiral structure within known as the
cochlea
would vibrate which converts the
physical energy of the wave
into electrical impulses which surge to
the brain for an auditory nerve
finally your brain does its human
calculator thing
to interpret those signals as sound
in your mind the bigger the vibrations
the louder the perceived
sound so in a nutshell
if a tree falls but there is nobody
there to hear it
then no according to science
it wouldn't make a sound because sound
is not a physical property of our world
it is simply the interpretation of
information
by the brain obviously there would still
be vibrations if you weren't around
during the tree's demise and those
physical vibrations will have a small
effect on the surrounding environment
but sound needs to be perceived to exist
and therefore requires a hearer to be
present
and i can sort of prove to you that
sound is not a physical property of our
world but something that only happens
inside your head because your brain can
be fooled pretty easily
take horror films for example it would
be
inconvenient and probably illegal to
convince an
actor to actually chew human flesh
but you can create a pretty convincing
zombie bite
by chomping down on a tomato
you can crush a pepper to replicate a
skull crush
and you can create the sound of
intestines being pulled out
by molesting a raw chicken which oddly
enough is not illegal
but we can take this neural trickery one
step further still
if part of an audio recording is
replaced by a period of silence
[Music]
the gaps would be quite obvious but
if someone starts coughing over someone
else speaking
your brain simply works out what should
be there
in place of the cuffs and fills in the
gaps
and here's an even cooler example listen
to this digital piano
and see if you notice anything odd
at first it just sounds like a cat
trapped inside a piano
having a seizure but observe what
happens
once words are put on the screen
[Music]
creepy right this is because our brains
utilize
context and prior knowledge to make
sense of the world around us you
understand english
only because of the prior knowledge your
brain possesses
and the context that that person you're
talking to
is speaking english icelandic is just a
bunch of complex vibrations
yet an icelandic native can decipher
those vibrations
because of his prior knowledge and
context
whereas you just hear the vague
grumblings of an angry viking
so for yet another time in this video to
answer the old chestnut if a tree falls
in a forest and no one is around to hear
it
does it make a sound no it creates a
disturbance of the air
but it does not make a sound
[Music]
course we also have to assume no animals
are present
since they have the same vibration to
sound conversion engine
otherwise called ears and the brain as
we do
but hold on a minute a tree has plenty
of other biological friends around it
what about plants evidence that plants
can and do respond to sound
has mounted over recent years we know
that sound stimuli can make plants
more tolerant towards infections more
resistant towards droughts
and even grow more quickly in one
experiment where plants were placed next
to an opaque
tube with water constantly rushing
through it
over time the plants grew towards the
tube
suggesting they could hear the water
passing through the pipe
this might come as a surprise especially
because plants lack one of the essential
components of hearing
an ear although we don't yet fully
understand how they pull it off
it's thoughts the bowl shape of many
flowers may have evolved
as a way to catch more of the vibrations
around them
and in a sense turn up the volume
on their environment the evening
primrose for example
produces a sweeter nectar roughly three
minutes
after hearing the sound of a bee buzzing
or a synthetic sound reproduced at a
similar frequency
but it won't respond to any other
frequencies
so maybe we should talk to plants to
help them grow
after all but be careful how you talk to
them
they don't respond well to shouting so
keep things sweet with a low
dusted toe ideally around 115
to 250 hertz so
it turns out if a tree falls in a forest
but no human
or animal is present to hear it it will
probably still make a sound
from the perspective of nearby plants
so far we've attempted to answer this
question using a combination of
philosophy
and science and surprisingly they both
agree
that perception plays a big role in
whether or not something makes a sound
where idealism and science differ
however
is that according to idealism a lack of
perception
equates to a lack of existence
and hence a lack of a tree
science on the other hand typically
assumes something definitely does exist
even if our senses aren't experiencing
it directly
take neptune for example scientists
predicted the existence of neptune
before they saw
it because there were discrepancies
between calculations and
data for the planet uranus using the
laws of physics einstein was able to
successfully predict the bending of
light
and the existence of black holes in the
1950s scientists were able to
anticipate rising co2 levels
and we now work on the assumption that
dark energy
exists a type of energy that acts in
opposition to gravity
yet we still haven't observed it and
perhaps we never will
but as science evolves so may the answer
to the classic
falling tree conundrum einstein believed
the world continues to function
exactly the same regardless if we are
around to observe it
as he so eloquently puts god does not
play dice with the universe
some quantum physicists however beg to
differ
they argued that each of us lives within
our own
virtual reality of sorts and the
universe behaves in a unique way
depending on who is observing it and
from where
this mind-melting concept was conceived
by niels bohr
and werner heisenberg back in the 1920s
and is known as the copenhagen
interpretation
it's an idea so convoluted even its
creators
bow and heisenberg couldn't agree with
each other
about what it actually was whether you
subscribe to quantum mechanics
established science idealism or
pastafarianism
i think the real lesson here is that
it's our experiences
of life and the world around us not
the objects themselves that give us
real meaning perhaps in a peculiar
and somewhat reckless way this was what
the timber tyrant of weybridge was
trying to tell us all
by chopping down 50 trees but let's be
honest he was probably just stupid and
blind drunk
thanks for watching check out my new
podcast
random interesting facts available on
youtube spotify
apple podcast and anywhere else you get
your podcasts
link in the description below thanks